that morning
on the morning of september 11th i
finally was because all the cell phones
went down
if you had a cell phone right because
they were new then
but all that went down and i finally
found a landline around 11
15 a.m eastern time where i was able to
get through
to my younger brother chris who i was
very close with
and tell him my words to him were
i'm alive but everyone else is dead
because all my friends were killed
over 100 of my friends were killed uh
all my you know they were my all my
buddies you know they were
men i uh loved
and um so those were my exact words
so in the days after
i still work for the mayor you know you
don't stop because something bad
happened you still were you're still at
work
and we're waiting for more terrorist
attacks to occur
like we we
are scared out of our minds about what's
gonna happen
next right and the military's coming in
and
all the cops are in the street trying
you know trying to make sense of things
and
what were your orders immediately after
that like what were you
what was your job set up set up afford
command posts
mayor's command post kind of we were
trying to get
a handle on all the
incoming help everybody
got in their police cars and their fire
trucks
in their military vehicles and drove to
new york city
so we had this influx of help it's the
beauty of america and the beauty of
humanity right everybody wanted to help
but we don't know who's who there's no
organized process for all we know
on you know that ambulance that's
driving into ground zero
is full of a bomb you know we don't know
and we're and we're genuinely scared
that something else is going to happen
and so
our first job was to try and manage the
incoming
people and equipment and to try to vet
it somehow and
and not
send to send down to the scene
what they need not what they don't need
they don't need
hundreds and thousands of people coming
down who are going to get in the way
they need people who have skills talent
training
equipment that's going to help them
in these days and moments we are still
believing
that we have many many people alive
under the rubble
so we set up the forward command post at
is 89 on the west side
highway and i had the day shift
representing the mayor and we were
starting to
direct we were starting to get a a
barrier
around the neighborhood that was being
manned by first law enforcement and then
by the national guard
so we were starting to be able to lock
it down
and so people they would send people to
the gym or cafeteria where i was in the
school
and then we had to try to figure out how
to vet people
get ids made up all that
it was to say it was chaotic is such an
understatement there should be some
other word
bigger than that uh
i was standing on this it was it was an
intermediate school so the chairs were
small
little kids chairs i was standing on one
of them yelling
out orders and organizing organizing and
trying
to be helpful in trying to provide
leadership
and a guy comes over to me and like tugs
on my
shirt and he has an id and
he puts it up to me he says i'm fbi
see that's my picture that's my id i am
an fbi agent i was like okay
he's like we have a problem in the room
i need to talk to you
so i get off the chair he grabs me he
said there's a guy in this room wearing
a blue jacket with yellow fbi
letters emblazoned on it
he's not from the fbi i know everybody
he's not he's not one of us
i don't know who he is and he has a
backpack
and you know we are waiting for someone
to blow up a backpack at our command
post
[ __ ] so i grab a nypd guy
and we explained it to him you know
there's a possible bomber in the room
and so he's like we got some under nypd
undercovers we're going to surround him
then we're going to take him down
so they surrounded him with some
undercover nypd guys
and i imagine this scene i'm not making
this up it really happened
the guy's in a fbi jacket and all of a
sudden
a bunch of scruffy-looking
guys take him out hard
out down they they rip the backpack out
of his hand in case he had a triggering
device
and they separate him they put him up
against the wall they put him in cuffs
and the guy's screaming i'm fbi i'm fbi
i'm fbi
and so we confront him
after the cops took him down and were
like
the guy with me that's a real fbi agent
is like you're not
he used some follow language you say it
you're not a [ __ ] fbi agent right i'm
i know i am this is my id who the [ __ ]
are you
we were pissed to say the least
and it turns out he was like cia guy
and the dope
who was puts on an fbi jacket didn't
tell the fbi
you know he just like walked in there
like he owned the joint and i i only i'm
not picking
i'm not picking on anybody i'm saying
that's how
paranoid and scared we were right um
and how everything triggered us because
we were afraid of getting blown up again
what are you currently working on well i
i'm i'm in a
i'm on a task force which i can't really
talk about it's national security stuff
uh but um we we are involved with
prosecuting terrorists in in uh
ensuring that american justice is done
the way america does it right we don't
we don't just you know shoot them in the
head
if we can capture them we capture them
and we get intelligence out of them
uh hopefully uh and and then we
prosecute them
in a in a court an american court so
whether that's a military court or an
american court
of justice federal court
it's still the prosecution the defense
and the judiciary that
develop evidence and
allow evidence in or not and then
you're judged by a group of uh of
your peers and they decide whether
you're guilty or not
and um and then they decide the judge
decides what the sentence is right
so um we still
do that i'm proud of being a part of
that we cannot become
like some of these other countries are
we still
need to even with the worst people
that do the most egregious things to
america and to americans
we still have to do a fair trial
and i do believe in that and i'm honored
to be a part of it
um
and so we have some time left in doing
this
uh and then at some point i think i'm
going to be done with it all
yeah you know it's 20 years coming up
we have the anniversary coming up
less than a year from now right um we
have some big
things planned uh one of the foundations
i'm i'm
proud to be a part of is the steven
siller tunnel
towers foundation and we have some
concerts we've been we've announced some
big concerts that are going to benefit
the foundation
so i'm proud to be a part of that and
then after the 20th anniversary
and after this position with the feds
i'm in
uh i think i might just walk on the
beach a bit yeah you know that sounds
like a good plan yeah
so you can't say who you're specifically
employed by right now or federal
just federal government yeah okay yeah
in general because then it gets into a
whole thing which i can't get into so
um are you doing lots of traveling i do
some travel yeah
back and forth to dc um and
uh and then some other places uh
but most of my work for the job is in
new york city working with the families
and
i